Good morning John! It's my last Pizzamas
video. I can't beli...it went by so fast.
Though it was a very long couple of weeks.
It had happy times and sad times and reunion videos
and charity galas and now I'm in New
Hampshire visiting family and I want to
be clear that this is an unusual level
of weird. However, I would be lying if I
said that my life hasn't gotten really
weird and really cool and really
wonderful and really complicated over
the last eight or nine years of us
making VlogBrothers videos. My life is
not normal. I don't think any lives are
normal, but my life is clearly not normal
and I am a number of things that I was
not in 2006. I and professionally
respected, fairly well known, and
thus one might say that I am a success.
Ever since people have started to say this to me
that like "what's it like to be
successful ? " or "Congratulations on your
success". I have felt really weird about it.
Troubled by it and I was having a hard
time figuring out exactly why I was
feeling this way. Is it modesty? Is
it false modesty? Maybe a bit of both of those.
But after thinking about this for a while.
Here's what it actually is. I feel like
when someone says "congratulations on
your success" they're putting you into a
category of people that...that is
extremely difficult to achieve.
That only a very small percentage of humans on the
planet could ever achieve
and then saying that that is a thing that all
people should strive for.
Despite the fact that the only way that something
like this can happen to you is if
happened to stumble across a great big
pile of steaming luck and then fall into
it and get stuck all over your body and it's like... I can't get this luck off of me!
There isn't enough space in human brains
for everyone to be known by a large
number of people. And that's what fame is. Weirdly, it's just the ability to have
your face recognized by a larger than
average number of people....Yeah.
Look, I'm very happy. I'm a happy person. But I was happy before I was "successful".
I was happy in 2006. I had great
friends in great family and I was
working on interesting projects and I
had learned a lot of things and I was
excited to learn more and I don't think
that most people would even argue that
success is a necessary part of happiness. But I think we do conflate those two things.
And whenever I am told that I'm successful. I worry
about what that word means to the person
saying it and what it means to society. Does it mean achieving the things
you want to achieve? Which is the good
definition.
I want to do things and then I did do
those things and thus I am a success. I
have succeeded. Or is it achieving
something that most people implicitly
cannot achieve. It is impossible for most
people to have because it's based on the
scarcity of resources. It's based on the
fact that not everyone can be famous.
It's based on the fact that not everyone
can be in the top twenty percent of
income.
Is being successful being richer or more powerful or more well known
than most people? That kind of societally recognized
implicit success is something
that I think we all crave and it is
something that I have to some extent... but
I don't think it's something that I need
to feel valued and valuable and it's not
something that I... it's definitely not
something I need to feel happy. I think that it
is very societally important that we
figure out ways to value ourselves and
value each other that don't have
anything to do with scarcity. You know
the scarcity of money,
the scarcity of of fame, the scarcity of power even.
I would much rather be and much rather associate myself with
the kind of people who want
to have a positive impact on a small
number of people. Than to collect a great
deal of wealth and power even at the
expense of other people. So John. As I finish off
my final Pizzamas video of 2015.
I don't know what "success" is! I still don't.
I know what "successes" are.
Individual things. But the the acquisition of
success and "being a success" I think
that's kind of a made up thing. But I am very
grateful. What I'm grateful for is having
great friends and great family and a
great community who make me feel valued
who make me question myself and
question my beliefs and challenge me
to do interesting and difficult things...
and to become a better person.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday... Or No!
Friday I'll see you tomorrow!
Which means, yes! We only have one day left of Pizzamas.
One day left for to get the shirts and the other products at DFTBA.com
and thank you to everybody for a really great Pizzamas.